Cole Sprouse and Lily Reinhart have gone
their separate ways the Riverdale
co-stars have called it quits after
nearly two years together according to
multiple reports the news comes just
days after they attended comic-con with
their Riverdale co-stars Wow things
didn't appear out of the ordinary during
their panel on Sunday where the two were
seated next to each other and I
witnessed lzt that the two kept their
distance at a party the night before
et's source explains quote Lily spent
most of the night with her female
co-stars while Cole was on the other
side of the party hanging out with
different friends the two also stopped
by et's comic-con suite on saturday
where they assured fans that their
characters Jughead Jones and Betty
Cooper worked stronger than ever I think
they're going strong chuck it goes to
prep school this season so he's only
back in Riverdale on the weekends that
distance yeah and I think that's going
to inevitably put stress on the
relationship between Betty and Jughead I
think it might be a little bit tense
they might fall turn away from each
other only to come back together way
stronger and yeah I think they're gonna
I think they're going to be really good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]